No matter how skilled a writer, director,
or editor might be, there are always going
to be scenes or sequences that end up cut
from a finished film. Whether it's original
endings that didn't work with audiences, or
scenes that just couldn't fit the running
time, these scenes and alternate takes are
ones fans need to know about. Here are Screen
Rant's 10 Amazing Movie Scenes You've Never
Seen.
Interstellar
No matter how confusing the ending of Christopher
Nolan's space epic was, it wrapped up almost
all of the suspense: the hero Coop sends the
science needed to save humanity back in time,
before he travels back to Earth to meet his
elderly daughter, and heads out to find another
astronaut stranded on humanity's new home.
Some viewers had a problem with such a neat
and tidy ending, but the original script had
the wormhole to earth collapse when Coop sent
the data back. It apparently would have ended
with him floating inside a black hole, never
knowing if humans died out, before eventually
running out of air. They probably went with
the better ending in this case.
The Shining
One of the most iconic horror movies of all
time, The Shining was always as flawless as
it's remembered to be. The movie originally
ended with the father, Jack, frozen in the
hedge maze, as his wife and son are treated
at a nearby hospital. The hotel manager shows
up claiming that there was no evidence of
any of the movie's action. Just when audiences
start to wonder if it was all in the characters'
heads, it's revealed that the manager knew
the truth all along, and even hired Jack to
keep the murders coming. After testing the
film in theatres, director Stanley Kubrick
cut the scene from every print.
Vacation
The movie that introduced the Griswold family
to the world was an instant hit, spawning
multiple sequels of disastrous family vacations.
The family's cross-country road trip to Walley
World - a parody of Walt Disney's famous theme
park - ends with them finding the park closed
- until they force their way in with a guard
held at gunpoint. But the original ending
was even weirder, sending Clark and his family
to the home of the park's founder, forcing
HIM to entertain them at gunpoint. The ending
tested so badly with audiences, it was completely
re-shot, but was softened up a bit and used
for Christmas Vacation years later.
Mad Max Fury Road
Tom Hardy takes up Mel Gibson's role as the
drifter Max Rockatansky in Fury Road, helping
a group of women escape from a madman's fortress
and, eventually, reclaim it. According to
director George Miller, the movie originally
was planned to have Max return to the Citadel,
and reveal that he had fallen in love with
Furiosa, leaving them to build a new and better
city. It was Tom Hardy who challenged the
director, claiming that Max would be nowhere
near ready for a new family or responsibility.
Miller realized he was wrong, and the new
ending was shot instead, with Max Disappearing
back into the Wasteland with a single nod.
Terminator 3: Rise of the Machines
The third Terminator movie isn't remembered
too fondly, but one deleted scene is must-see
viewing for any fan of the series. When cutting
edge combat robots are being sold to the US
Military, the real soldier the Terminator
are based on is finally revealed: Chief Master
Sargent Candy. Seeing Arnold Schwarzenegger
playing the man behind the machine may not
fit with the overall tone, but there's no
denying that it features some of the best
jokes in the franchise.
Edge ofTomorrow
Tom Cruise and writer Christopher McQuarrie's
time travel/alien invasion story tackled some
seriously complicated time loop tactics, forcing
the hero to relive the same defeat over and
over again. Until the ending, when he saves
the day, he is sent back to the helicopter
that set the movie in motion, wins the war,
and meets the woman of his dreams - for the
first and hopefully last time. But the original
ending was planned to be nowhere near as happy.
The hero still kills the villain, but the
movie would have ended when he wakes up a
day earlier - leaving the audience to wonder
if the entire story even happened, or will
happen all over again. It was only when Cruise
explained that the movie's comedy would be
stronger than expected that the director agreed
to give a happy ending to better fit the tone
of the story.
X-Men: First Class
The power of mind control can be a dangerous
thing in the wrong mutant's hands, so it's
a good thing the X-Men's Professor X always
acts responsibly. Well, almost always. When
Charles and Erik are out recruiting mutants
in First Class, Charles finds a unique way
of showing his power. Instead of just reading
one mutant's mind, he alters her perception,
making his metal-bending partner appear in
women's clothing without him ever being the
wiser. It's such a good gag, it really is
hard to believe it didn't make the finished
cut.
Star Wars
Remember when Obi-Wan warns Darth Vader that
killing him would make things even harder
on the former Jedi? The original trilogy doesn't
actually deliver on that warning the way you
would think - but that wasn't always the case.
George Lucas long considered having Obi-Wan
reappear in Luke's battle with the Emperor,
even using powers from beyond the grave to
keep the Sith Lord's powers from him. The
twist would have ended with both Obi-Wan and
Yoda being brought back to life... And old
Ben revealing Luke's Uncle Owen was actually
Owen Kenobi, his brother. The prequels changed
all that, but we can still dream of what might
have been.
Kill Bill
It's hard to believe that there were scenes
Quentin Tarantino was forced to leave out
of his Kill Bill epic, but one of the biggest
nods to the movie's Hong Kong action roots
wound up on the cutting room floor. The scene
from Volume 2 saw The Bride and Bill run into
an Australian martial artist out for revenge,
with Bill showing just how deadly he is, even
at an old age. It's easy to see why it was
cut for the flow of the second film, but Michael
Jai White's skills would have been more than
welcome for fans of flying fists.
The Wolverine
Logan took some time off from his brightly-coloured
X-Men allies for a solo story more in line
with westerns than a typical comic book movie.
But The Wolverine still planned to include
one of the greatest nods to the characters
comic book roots - and a costume that fans
have been begging for ever since he first
appeared on screen. The final scene would
have shown Logan receiving a gift, opening
the chest to find his classic comic costume,
complete with the brown and yellow mask. Out
of all the deleted scenes in comic book movies,
this is the one that definitely should have
made the final cut.
Those are the movie scenes too crazy, too
awesome, or too good to be true that we think
movie fans need to know about, but which ones
did we miss? Name them in the comments and
be sure to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one.